[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
why I can't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so
don't party later
right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this place
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
happy birthday
[Applause]
you're driving along today
Oh
see
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
all right
- stretching where is north
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's gonna be very short and I
just wanted to come down and began by
thank you everybody for being here mr.
America thank you thank you so so much
for your energy support from all over
the country for me it means a lot folks
you look I want to thank everyone we had
a great night last night and tremendous
support from all across the nation with
with victories in Texas Virginia and
North Carolina Arkansas Alabama
Tennessee Massachusetts and with just a
story we heard with one may as well know
it's gonna be a while before the final
results committed California but those
of you who are knocked down those of you
who have been counted out this is your
campaign this is your camp any look
we're gonna bring together all Americans
we did that we showed that last night
regarding race
gender or your disability your ethnicity
Democrats Republicans it depends
I'm very strike I really mean it this is
what we have to do it this is a woman to
unify the nation that's why I entered
the race in the first place to unify
this country so we welcome all those who
join us all those who want to join us
and build a move and this is a movement
and we need that move to beat Donald
Trump and to build a future we all know
is possible you know I'm especially
proud of our campaign is generating so
much enthusiasm driving up voter turnout
all across the nation this idea that we
did that movement look at the results
look at who's showing up we are bringing
out this campaign people behind me by
bringing out people who have not
participated and it's way up way up and
it sort of turns to me that positive
progressive vision we have been provided
for the nation is resonate resonating
all over the country to make sure health
care is affordable and accessible
everyone to make sure that every child
is a quality education regardless of the
zip code ended and and then to take on
and beat the NRA and the gun
manufacturers which promise you I will
do and not only protect social security
but what I've been from calling for some
time increasing benefits for the those
who are seniors and that
that our need now after they lost a
spouse earlier and would essentially run
out of their coverage because they were
living long thank God and securing it
for every generation that follows that's
the proposal we put forward and take on
the existential threat of climate change
you know and you know Carini and the
process will curve over ten million
good-paying job not 15 bucks an hour
forty five fifty bucks an hour benefits
that's just going to happen
and those people who may be displaced
for this process they're the ones who
get those jobs I was proud I was proud
to serve as President Obama's vice
president for for eight years and what
we were able accomplished from passing
Obamacare to the work we did to help
rescue the auto industry and and the
nation's economies where everybody kind
of forgets my mother used to have an
expression stood the greatest ability
got david.kairis ability to forget and
then she'd say if that weren't the case
women only had one child and we're just
getting ready we had just gotten economy
up and running again in a big way and
we're about to rebuild the middle class
in the way that we should be going and
now we will we were taken we took on the
climate change everything was just
beginning
well we know we have so much more do we
have to put in a bigger broader vision
for this nation and make it happen
and but first first we have to defeat
Donald Trump and so we have to keep the
Nancy Pelosi as a speaker in order to do
that we have to also win the Senate back
and that's how we're gonna this vision
that I have to the future that's how I'm
gonna be able make it a reality you know
what we can't have that happen in the
next few weeks is let this primary turn
email campaign a negative attacks the
only thing that can trump and it doesn't
do anything help any one of the
candidates or less than a campaign
threat to keep our eye on the ball and
the eye on the ball is to reclaim the
soul of this country I believe people
understand the bubble race if Donald
Trump poses an existential threat to our
standing in the world
he really does it they have to know that
he's family crying they all know these
fanned the flames of hate and sought to
divide us they've watched an insult
insult our allies and embraced
demagogues he's embracing dictators all
around the world at the same time or
alliances are weakened without any
question everyone see Pat has been he
and I know that if we give this man
another four years through the White
House and forever and fundamentally
change the character this nation we
can't let this happen
that's why from the moment I entered
this race I did say where the battle for
the soul of the station and we are now
it's on the Michigan Mississippi
Missouri and Idaho North Dakota
Washington State I'm going to take this
fight all across America to rebuild
middle class to give people an
opportunity that's been denied them
mr. president and do you know the next
president I said many times has to be
able to he or she has to bail on the
first day that they are elected
president they're sworn in stand in the
states and they're gonna face a divided
nation and a world of disarray and I
have to be able to know what they're
doing I know what I want to do I make it
clearer and clearer to all people in
this country country now and Election
Day and I believe we have our
significant opportunity see the
opportunity to move this country to
convene the 21st century only like we've
had any opportunity before I really
believe that with every fiber might be
mr. folks as I've said from the
beginning characters on the ballot I
love you to character the candidates
character in the nation so I'm looking
forward to it and again I thank you all
I'm not gonna take any questions I'm
sure you all have thousands of them and
you're gonna get a chance to ask me a
lot of those we go along I just wanted
to make a statement before I before I
headed out I'm doing another moment here
and I want to thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]